the string of lights seen all over the
valley are the talk of the town tonight
thank you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez this is
night two
and those orbs are actually satellites
launched by spacex
now they serve a pretty cool purpose but
some scientists worry it could cause too
much
crowding in space sasha loftis joining
us live she spoke with a local expert
and those who saw the lights in the sky
sasha
brian and denise the lights of las vegas
can actually
be seen from telescopes hundreds of
miles away
this kind of light pollution like you
see coming from the highway from the
strip
also happens in the sky now experts say
that it could affect
research in the coming years i never
seen nothing like that no
a string of lights sends las vegas
searching for answers
it was so weird it was almost like it
was fake some
called them planes while many others
believed they came from another world
are we being invaded or what everybody
was terrified
and we saw them so what were these
unlikely orbs
that took social media by storm itching
downrange
they were actually a cluster of
satellites called
starlink local astronomy expert jason
steffen says the constellation
launched by elon musk and spacex is
creating a broadband network in the sky
it has the goal of opening up the
internet to a wider variety of people
who otherwise don't have access to it
it's a remarkable achievement
but technology is adding up and he says
research
will take a hit as streaking satellites
create
more light pollution high-tech
instruments that are passing through the
field of view that just
kind of ruined the images that you're
taking and make it
a challenge to do data analysis but
stefan still
calls this a step in the right direction
for humanity as a whole
and i was like wow we really got to see
it with our own eyes and those who
witnessed it
were thrilled to catch this important
moment
in time a historic moment and a history
lesson as well
jason says those starling satellites
will be visible in the sky
for the foreseeable future but as more
time passes since that launch point
they will spread apart and you no longer
will see them in that cluster
they'll look more like kind of more dim
moving stars in the sky
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now